Speaking of Psychology is taking a winter break, so we're rerunning one of our favorite episodes from the past. In 2022, I talked to psychologist Jeff McDonald about how more Americans are single than ever before, and many of them are happy to stay that way. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology, we'll be back with new episodes in January. Thank you for listening. We talk a lot on this podcast about relationships, and there's no doubt that relationships can be an important driver of many people's health, happiness, and well-being.
《心理学畅谈》正在放寒冬假，因此我们重播了过去最受喜爱的单集之一。在2022年，我与心理学家杰夫·麦克唐纳（Jeff McDonald）探讨了为什么如今单身美国人的比例创下历史新高，且其中许多人很乐意维持现状。希望大家会喜欢这期来自资料库的节目。《心理学畅谈》将于1月携全新单集回归。感谢您的收听。在这个播客中，我们经常讨论人际关系，毫无疑问，人际关系可以成为许多人健康、快乐和幸福的重要驱动力。
But focusing solely on partnerships or romantic relationships misses a crucial fact. More Americans than ever before are single, and many are perfectly happy to stay that way. A 2019 Pew Research Center poll found that 3 in 10 U.S. adults are single. They're not married, living with a partner, or in a committed relationship. Among those singles, half said they were not interested in dating or looking for a woman. relationship. Meanwhile, looking simply at marriage rates, we find the number of singles is even higher. According to the U.S. Census Bureau, about 50% of American adults are unmarried, or close to 127 million people. Those singles are a diverse bunch. Some have never been married. Some are divorced, some
但如果仅仅把目光聚焦在伴侣关系或恋爱关系上，就会忽略一个至关重要的事实。如今单身美国人的比例创下了历史新高，而且许多人非常乐意保持这种状态。皮尤研究中心200年の一项民调发现，30%的美国成年人处于单身状态。他们没有结婚，没有与伴侣同居，也没有处于承诺关系中。在这些单身人士中，有一半表示他们对约会或寻找女性不感兴趣。关系。与此同时，如果只看结婚率，我们会发现单身的数量甚至更高。根据美国人口普查局的数据，大约50%的美国成年人未婚，相当于近1.27亿人。这些单身人士是一个多元化的群体。有些人从未结过婚。有些人离异了，有些人
widowed. They are older or younger. Some are parents. Others have no children. All of those factors, and many others may affect how people experience singlehood. So how is relationship status related to well-being. What makes some people happy with singlehood while others are not? Is there a societal stigma against singles? And if so, how does that stigma affect people's lives? Why is there so much more research on being in a happy relationship than on being happily single? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Jeff McDonald, a professor of psychology at the University of Toronto.
丧偶。他们有老有少。有些人是父母。其他人则没有孩子。所有这些因素以及许多其他因素，都可能会影响人们对单身生活的体验。那么，人际关系状态与幸福感究竟有何关联？是什么让一些人对单身生活感到快乐，而另一些人则不然？社会上是否存在针对单身人士的污名化？如果是这样，这种污名化又如何影响人们的生活？为什么关于处于幸福恋爱关系中的研究，远比关于快乐单身的研究要多得多？欢迎收听《心理学畅谈》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是多伦多大学心理学教授杰夫·麦克唐纳博士。
He has studied aspects of relationships for many years, including attachment theory and intimacy. More recently, he turned his attention to singlehood, and today, the primary aim of his lab is to better understand well-being in singlehood. His and his colleagues' research has started to create a portrait of what makes for a happy single person. So I'm looking forward to talking today about that and much more. Thank you for joining me, Dr. McDonald. It's my pleasure to be here. I mentioned that you studied relationships for many years before you started studying singlehood.
他多年来一直研究人际关系的各个方面，包括依恋理论和亲密关系。最近，他将注意力转向了单身生活，如今，他实验室的主要目标是更好地了解单身状态下的幸福感。他和同事的研究已经开始勾勒出一幅画像，描绘究竟是什么造就了一个快乐的单身人士。因此，我非常期待今天能与您探讨这个以及更多话题。非常感谢您能参加我们的节目，麦克唐纳博士。很高兴能来到这里。我提到过，你在开始研究单身生活之前，曾多年致力于人际关系的研究。
What made you turn your attention to single people? And why do you think it's important for researchers to study singlehood? I mean, I think the primary driver in turning my attention to singlehood is just recognizing, you know, like you said at the top there, there are a lot of single people out there. And that number is increasing, not just in the United States, not just in Canada. This seems to be a worldwide trend. So it's something that's important to pay attention to, but we know really very little about who single people are and what makes single people happy.
是什么促使你将注意力转向单身人士？你认为研究单身生活对研究人员来说为什么很重要？我的意思是，促使我将注意力转向单身生活的主要驱动力，其实就是认识到，正如你刚才开篇所说的那样，现实中有大量的单身人士。而且这个数字还在不断增加，不仅在美国，不仅在加拿大。这似乎是一个全球性的趋势。因此，这是一个值得关注的重要课题，但对于单身人士究竟是谁，以及是什么让他们感到快乐，我们其实知之甚少。
And even if you just want to take this from the perspective of a relationship researcher, everybody is single before they get in their first relationship. Most of the time when you end a relationship, you end up single. So, you know, it's important to not think about this as two different groups of people, largely speaking. These are different phases of most people's lives. And so even if your goal is just to understand relationships, you need to understand singlehood. But I think understanding single people is important in its own right. A lot of research over the years has found evidence that on average, married people are
而且，即使你仅仅从人际关系研究人员的角度来看，每个人在进入第一段感情之前都是单身的。大多数时候，当一段感情结束时，你最终也会恢复单身。所以，从广义上讲，没必要把这看作是两类完全不同的人。这些只是大多数人生命中的不同阶段。因此，即使你的目标仅仅是理解人际关系，你也需要理解单身生活。但我认为，理解单身人士本身就具有重要意义。多年来的许多研究发现证据表明，平均而言，已婚人士比单身人士更
happier, healthier, and generally have better life outcomes compared with single people. But some researchers who study singlehood have pushed back against that idea. What do you think? Are partnered people generally better off than those who are single? Is that even the right question to ask? I think it's one of the right questions to ask, but it's not the only one. And, you know, I certainly think I should say off the top that this is such a young field of research. So we have some initial things to say about it. But I think all of this is up for debate and discussion. You know, from my reading of the literature, I think it would be fair to say that the average person who is in a romantic relationship is higher in well-being. They're happier. They're higher in life satisfaction than the average person who is single. But there's so much variability within each. group. Not every single person is miserable and certainly not everybody in a relationship is ecstatic with their life. So that's really been the focus of what we've been doing at
快乐、更健康，并且通常拥有更好的人生结果。但一些研究单身生活的研究人员对这一观点提出了反思。你怎么看？有伴侣的人真的普遍比单身的人过得更好吗？这甚至是一个正确的问题吗？我认为这是一个正确的问题，但并非唯一的问题。而且，我当然首先要说的是，这是一个非常年轻的研究领域。所以我们目前只能提供一些初步的见解。但我认为所有这一切都还有待辩论和探讨。从我对相关文献的阅读来看，可以说，处于恋爱关系中的普通人，其幸福感确实更高。他们更快乐。与单身者相比，他们的生活满意度平均更高。但每个群体内部都存在着巨大的差异。并非每个单身人士都痛苦不堪，当然也并非恋爱中的每个人都对生活欣喜若狂。所以这确实是我们实验室一直以来工作的重点，我想也是许多单身研究人员一直在做的，那就是研究快乐的单身人士与不太快乐的单身人士的区别，从而弄清楚哪些类型的单身人士生活得很好，而哪些类型的单身人士可能过得不那么好。
our lab and I think a lot of singlehood researchers have been doing is, you know, looking at who are the happier versus less happy single people to get a sense of, you know, which types of single people are doing really well for themselves and which types of single people might not be doing so well. One of the central questions in your lab is what makes people happier content with being single. Are there common traits that happy singles share personality traits or life, circumstances, or other things? There's a few things that we seem to be starting to put our finger on now. So one, for example, is that people who have never been married or people who have
你们实验室的核心问题之一，是什么让人对单身生活感到更快乐、更满足。快乐的单身人士之间是否存在共同的特征，比如人格特质、生活环境或其他方面？我们现在似乎已经开始摸索出一些头绪了。比如其中一点，那就是从未结过婚的人，或者那些
never been in a romantic relationship tend to be happier singles than people who have been. We don't really have any direct evidence as to why that's the case, but my guess would be people know what's good for them. And there's a reason why some people don't choose to be in romantic relationships because they know that's not what's going to make them happy. And, you know, the flip side of that is that one of the groups that does less well with singlehood is people who've been through a divorce. There is some evidence that suggests that divorce can have a bit of a damaging effect on at least some people, which, you know, we think is particularly interesting because the bias tends to be that romantic relationships are good for people. But if you think about the way that
从未谈过恋爱的人，往往比那些有过恋爱经历的人更能享受单身。我们其实没有直接的证据来解释为什么会这样，但我的猜测是，人们很清楚什么对自己最有利。有些人之所以不选择谈恋爱，是因为他们知道那并不能带给自己快乐，这是有原因的。反过来说，在单身生活中过得不太好的群体之一，就是经历过离婚的人。有一些证据表明，离婚至少会对某些人产生一定的负面破坏性影响，我们认为这特别有趣，因为人们往往带着一种偏见，认为恋爱关系对人有益。但如果你仔细想想，
people come out of divorces maybe less well off than when they started, relationships can actually be damaging, right? But there's a reason that as a society we haven't thought about relationships is damaging. The assumption is that they're good. So, you know, relationship history, I think, is an important one. Generally speaking, the tack that I tend to take on this is that the people who are doing well in singlehood are sort of the people who are good at life in general. That, you know, people, for example, who are higher in attachment security. So these would be the kinds of people who are comfortable making close relationships with people and who are not really worried so much about getting rejected by other people. I mean, they do well in romantic relationships, but our evidence suggests that these are people who do well in singlehood as well.
人们在经历离婚后的状况可能还不如开始时那么好，可见亲密关系实际上也可能具有破坏性，对吧？但这就是为什么作为一个社会，我们从未将人际关系视为具有破坏性的原因。人们的默认假设是它们总是好的。所以，我认为恋爱史是一个很重要的因素。总的来说，我倾向于采取这样的看法：那些在单身生活中过得很好的人，本质上就是那些擅长过好生活的人。比如，那些依恋安全性更高的人。这类人能够很舒适地与他人建立亲密关系，并且不太担心被别人拒绝。我的意思是，他们在恋爱关系中表现得很好，但我们的证据表明，这些人在单身生活中同样也能过得很好。
Maybe one of the reasons for that is that people who are happier in singlehood are also people who have good relationships with their friends and good relationships with their families. And that skill set that comes with a touch and security, the ability to be comfortably close to people to take emotional risks that are allow you to get close to people, that's not just limited to romantic relationships. Those people are going to bring those kinds of skills to their friendships and their family relationships. And I do think, you know, there's a bit of old-fashioned wisdom here that I think that some people have the idea that when you get into a romantic relationship, that then you're going to become a happy person.
这其中的原因之一可能在于，在单身生活中更快乐的人，往往也跟朋友和家人保持着良好的关系。而依恋安全感所带来的那套技能——那种能够安然与他人亲近、敢于冒情感风险去接近他人的能力——并不仅仅局限于恋爱关系。这些人会把这些技能同样运用到他们的友情和亲情之中。而且我的确认为，这里面包含了一些老派的智慧，有些人有一种想法，认为只要你谈了恋爱，你自然就会变成一个快乐的人。
But when you understand the kinds of people who are happy single are also the kinds of people who are happy in relationships, it suggests that maybe the best idea is to get right with yourself first and go towards a romantic relationship. relationship when you've done whatever that work is. Now, when you're studying people who are single, does that mean that they can't have relationships, that they can't have, you know, intimacy with other people? Yeah, no, not at all. I mean, certainly in terms of their friendship and their family relationships, there's lots
但当你意识到那些单身时快乐的人，往往也是在恋爱中快乐的人时，这表明也许最好的方法是先处理好自己的内心情感，在完成了这些个人成长的工作之后，再去追求恋爱关系。那么，当你研究单身人士时，这是否意味着他们不能拥有人际关系，不能与其他人拥有亲密关系呢？是的，完全不是这样。我的意思是，当然，就他们的友情和家庭关系而言，那里有大量的
of opportunity for intimacy there. One of the projects that we have ongoing in the lab right now is also looking at the romantic and sexual kinds of connections that single people have. So certainly, you know, over the last, like, however many decades, social norms have changed around opportunities for casual sexual opportunities or relationships that sort of straddle the line between dating and not dating, like friends with benefits. Friends with benefits. That's what I was thinking to. Yeah, exactly. So, you know, we know that there are a number of single people who tell us that they're sexually active, but we haven't really collected the data yet on, well, what kinds of relationships are those? And so we're, you know, we're trying to delve into that a little bit. what we do know is that single people who are higher in sexual satisfaction tend to be happier with singlehood. But the other part of that is that the data suggest to us that singles who are happier with their sex lives are also more likely to end up in relationships down the road.
亲密关系的发展空间。我们实验室目前正在进行的项目之一，也是在研究单身人士所拥有的浪漫和性连接。当然，在过去几十年的时间里，社会规范围绕着随意性行为的机会，或者介于约会与不约会之间（比如“炮友”）的关系，发生了变化。炮友。我也是这么想的。对，完全正确。所以，我们知道有许多单身人士告诉我们他们有性生活，但我们还没有真正收集到关于这些到底是些什么样关系的数据。因此，我们正在努力对此进行一些深入探讨。我们确实了解的是，性满意度更高的单身人士，往往对单身生活也更满意。但另一方面，数据也表明，性生活更满意的单身者，未来也更有可能最终走进恋爱关系。
And so, you know, one of our guesses about that is that, you know, being with people in sexual and romantic relationships, it's not like shopping for a product where if you don't like it, you take it back. You know, the human heart works such that relationships are kind of sticky. And even when you are in casual sexual relationships, for example, next thing, you know, you're leaving a toothbrush. And next thing, you know, you're leaving a set of pajamas. And next thing, you know, it's easier to just move in because you're already spending three nights a week there, right? So we think that even though sexual satisfaction is definitely something that's associated with happiness and singlehood, that might also indicate somebody who's on the road to being in a committed romantic relationship. Let me ask how age affects people's experience of singlehood. Do people become more or less content with being single as they get older?
所以，我们对此的一个猜测是，与人们建立性与浪漫关系，并不像去商店买产品，如果不喜欢就可以退货。人类的心灵运作方式使得人际关系具有某种“粘性”。即使你处于随意的性关系中，比如说，不知不觉中，你把牙刷留在了对方那里。不知不觉中，你把一套睡衣留下了。再不知不觉中，搬过去一起住变得轻而易举，因为你一周已经有三个晚上待在那里了，对吧？因此我们认为，尽管性满意度确实与单身时的幸福感相关，但这可能也预示着某人正走在通往承诺关系的道路上。请问年龄是如何影响人们对单身生活的体验的？随着年龄的增长，人们对单身的满意度是会增加还是减少？
So our evidence suggests that there's kind of an inflection point around midlife, that single people starting at about age 40 start to become more satisfied with being single. It's important to point out that that's not unique to singlehood, that it looks like there's some evidence suggesting that well, being in general for people tends to increase after about midlife. So there's another study by Unina Bueller where she looked at are people happy with the romantic relationships? And she found exactly the same pattern. Starting at about age 40, people start to become happier with the relationships. So, you know, it kind of looks like around midlife, people start to become happier with the path that they've chosen. I do think another factor in that, though, is some people who want to be in a relationship gets selected out of the singles pool, that if you're younger and
我们的证据表明，在步入中年左右，会出现一个转折点，单身人士从40岁左右开始，对单身状态变得更加满意。需要指出的是，这并非单身生活所独有，一些证据表明，人们总体上的幸福感似乎在过了中年之后往往也会增加。因此，乌妮娜·比勒（Unina Bueller）的另一项研究探讨了人们是否对恋爱关系感到满意，她发现了完全相同的模式。从40岁左右开始，人们开始对他们的恋爱关系变得更加满意。所以，这看起来就像是在中年左右，人们开始对自己选择的人生道路感到更加满意。不过，我认为其中的另一个因素是，那些想要谈恋爱的人会逐渐从单身群体中流失，如果你还年轻且
you'd really like to be in a relationship, you're more likely to actually end up dating. And so maybe the part of the reason that older singles are happier being single is that there's going to be less of them in that pool who wish that they were in a relationship. Now, having said that, in another study that we conducted, what the data looked like is that for older people who don't let go of wanting a relationship, like that variable of do you want to be in a romantic relationship or not, also seems to be something that's important in understanding whether people are happy with being single or not, that particularly older women who have let go of the desire or who never had a desire for romantic relationship in the first place are our
非常渴望拥有一段感情，你实际上就更有可能去约会。因此，年长单身人士更享受单身生活的部分原因，或许在于这个群体中那些内心期盼着恋爱的人变少了话虽如此，在我们进行的另一项研究中，数据表明，对于那些并未放弃渴望恋爱愿望的老年人来说——“你想不想谈恋爱”这个变量，对于理解人们是否对单身感到快乐似乎同样重要——特别是那些已经放下对恋爱渴望、或者从未有过恋爱渴望的老年女性，成为了我们
highest group in terms of life satisfaction. But it's the people who, as they get older, continue to wish that they were in a romantic relationship. That seems to be associated with lower life satisfaction. So there's something about making peace with your circumstances, letting go of things that you can't have that might also be part of this process of becoming a happy single person in an older age. I believe that most of your research is with people in the U.S., right? We've conducted studies with people in the U.S., with Europeans. We've done a little bit of data collection in Korea, but we haven't really expanded
生活满意度最高的群体。然而，那些随着年龄增长，仍然持续渴望谈恋爱的人，其生活满意度则相对较低。因此，与生活现状达成和解、放下那些无法拥有的东西，似乎也是步入老年后成为一个快乐单身人士过程中的一部分。我相信你的大部分研究对象都是美国人，对吧？我们对美国人和欧洲人进行过研究，也在韩国收集过少量数据，但我们在文化层面上尚未进一步扩展到其他地区。那么在你做过的研究中，是否发现过文化差异呢？在不同的国家，单身状态、人们如何体验单身以及单身是如何被看待的，是否存在差异？你知道，我会说，到目前为止我们还没有收集到足够的数据来很好地回答这个问题。我认为这是一个非常重要的问题。我的意思是，可以说到目前为止，通过我们在韩国进行的研究所得出的结果，我们
out culturally beyond that. Are there cultural differences, then, in the research that you've done, have you found in other countries that there is a difference in singlehood, how it's experienced and how what's perceived? You know, I would say that so far we haven't collected enough data to be able to answer that question well. I think it is such an important question. I mean, I would say so far with the research that we've been conducting in Korea, we've been
感到惊讶的是这两种文化之间存在着如此多的相似之处。例如，当你问单身人士：“你人生最重要的优先事项是什么？”无论是在韩国还是在我们收集过数据的西方国家，他们的回答都是：“我最重要的优先事项是我的家庭和健康。”而他们认为最不重要的优先事项（至少在我们列出的选项中）是性和约会。这一点在两个国家是一致的。不过，我们推测过的一点是（其他实验室也对此做过一点研究），那就是在不同的文化中，家庭在单身人士生活中所扮演的角色。美国尤其独特。从某些
surprised at the similarities across the two cultures. So, for example, when you ask single people, you know, what are your most important life priorities in both Korea and in the West where we've collected data, they say, my most important priorities are my family and my health. And they say that my least important priorities, at least of the ones that we ask them, are sex and dating. And that was something that was consistent across those two countries. But one of the things that we've speculated about, and there has been a little bit of research in other labs about, is the role that family plays in single people's lives across different cultures. You know, the U.S. in particular is unique. It is, you know, by some
标准来看，它字面意义上就是世界上最具个人主义色彩的国家，这意味着在这种体系下，你的家庭对你的约会和婚姻生活并没有太多的发言权。这其实非常罕见。在世界上大多数国家，家庭对你是否在约会、你在和谁约会这类事情有着相当大的发言权。因此，这就合乎逻辑地意味着，在这些更具集体主义色彩的国家里，单身人士可能会面临某种相当激烈的动态压力。因为这里存在着一种
measures literally the most individualistic country in the world, which means that it's a system where your family doesn't have a lot of say in what you're dating and your marriage life is. That's really unusual. In most countries around the world, family has a pretty big say about, you know, are you dating? Who are you dating? That kind of thing. And so it would make sense that that would lead to some kind of intense dynamics for single people in these more collectivistic kinds of countries where we would expect, because there's
文化规范，认为你是我们家族的代表。你应该结婚。你没结婚让我们家族丢脸了。因此，他们可能会承受某种特殊的压力，迫使他们不能保持单身，即便内心深处这正是他们想要的。我认为这将是未来研究的一个非常重要的方向。目前我们对此还没有太多确凿的结论。你们有没有发现性别之间存在差异？单身男性比单身女性更快乐，反之亦然吗？在这方面我们感到很惊讶。我们在多项研究中都考察了性别差异，但并没有发现男性和女性之间存在太多差异。
cultural norms around you're a representative of our family. You're supposed to be getting married. You're making us look bad by not getting married. That there could be some particular pressure on them to not be single, even if that in their heart is what they want to be. So I think that's going to be a really important direction for future research. We don't have a lot to say about that yet. Are you finding differences between the sexes? Are single men happier than single women or vice versa? We've been surprised in that regard. You know, we have. I've looked at gender differences in a number of our studies and haven't found a lot of differences between men and women.
我知道存在一些文化成见，认为男性特别是随着年龄增长，单身生活会过得非常艰难。总的来说，目前的现实数据在这方面要模棱两可得多。单身时的男性在社会支持方面似乎确实比女性过得更难一些，例如男性的支持性友谊往往较少。因此这可能对他们来说有点挣扎。但总体而言，我们一直在观察的数据，比如平均而言你对单身生活的满意度等数字，往往并没有太多的差异。我们怀疑的是，在这些数字背后，人们体验的具体内容可能会有所不同。
I know that there's some sort of cultural tropes that men in particular as they get older going to really struggle with singlehood. Generally speaking, the data so far are more equivocal on that. It does seem to be true that men, when they're single, struggle more than women do with social support, so that men will tend to have less supportive friendships, for example. And so that can be a bit of a struggle for them. But generally speaking, the data that we've been looking at, the numbers in terms of like how on average are you happy with singlehood, for example, there doesn't tend to be a lot of difference. What we suspect is that underneath those numbers, the content of people's experiences might be different.
所以，举个例子，如果你是一个单身女性，人们对你的刻板印象会与你是一个单身男性的情况有所不同，对吧？比如女性如果单身会被视为冷漠，而对男性来说则未必如此。并且存在一些贬义词来定义单身女性，比如“老处女”。而对男性来说并没有完全对应的词汇。是的，确实没有。无论如何暂时还没有。刚才你谈到了单身生活中的依恋关系。我想知道你是否能多谈谈依恋理论，以及它如何与单身生活和你的研究工作相关联？当然，可以的。依恋理论基本上是一个用来解释为什么有些人比另一些人更能适应与他人亲近的理论。这项理论最初的发展带有非常浓厚的心理动力学色彩，其核心观点是：你在童年中受到某种特定的对待，从而学会了如何与他人互动。最近，有一些纵向研究探讨了，这其中究竟有多少成分真正
So, you know, for example, if you were a single woman, there's going to be different stereotypes about you than if you're a single man, right? Like women, for example, are seen as cold if they're single, and that might not necessarily be the case for men. And there are some negative words that define women who are single like spinster. There's nothing quite equivalent for a man. No, there's not. Not yet anyways. A few moments ago, you talked about attachment in singlehood. I'm wondering if you could talk a little bit more about attachment theory and how that relates to singlehood and the work that you do. Sure, yeah. So attachment theory is, you know, basically a theory to explain why is it that some people are more comfortable getting close to others than other people are? You know, the original development of theory had this very psychodynamic kind of event to it where the idea was you get treated a particular way in childhood and that teaches you how to interact with other people. More recently, there's been some longitudinal research that has looked at, you know, how much of this is really.
根植于童年。对此目前存在一些疑问。所以，我认为依恋关系中关于童年的那部分如今正在经历一些转变。但从依恋理论的角度来看，绝对清晰的一点是，你可以衡量人们在如何与他人相处方面存在稳定的性格差异。因此，我们通常用来思考人们在与他人交往方式上存在差异的两个维度，就是我们所称的“焦虑型依恋”和“回避型依恋”这两个变量。对于焦虑型依恋的人，我的意思是，这类人通常会被通俗地认为是“需要陪伴又黏人”的类型。
really rooted in childhood. And there's some questions about that. So, you know, I think that that part of attachment being about childhood is a little bit in flux these days. But what is absolutely clear from an attachment theory perspective is that you can measure stable personality differences in how people relate to other people. So the two dimensions on which we typically think of differences in people about how they relate to others are these two variables that we call anxious attachment and avoid an attachment. So, anxiously attached people. I mean, these are the kinds of people who you would sort of colloquially think about is the needy and clingy type.
也就是那种需要大量关注、渴望得到认可的人，因为他们对自己感觉不是很好。但同时他们在接近其他人时又会感到非常犹豫，因为他们极度害怕被拒绝。因此，在他们的关系中可能会同时存在这种强烈的靠近与退缩的动态。至于回避型依恋的人，回避型依恋的人则是你通常会认为是“独立型”的人。他们很可能会告诉你，他们其实并不真的需要人际关系。我总是喜欢说，如果去车里拿八袋杂货回家时，你是那种想要一个人把它们全扛完的人，那你可能就是回避型依恋。他们是那种不太喜欢依赖他人、不喜欢从别人那里获得太多帮助的人。因此，我们做了一些研究来探讨：人们在与他人相处时的这些个体差异，
So the person who needs a lot of attention, they want validation because they don't feel so great about themselves. But they also feel really hesitant in approaching other people because they're really scared of getting rejected. So they can have this kind of strong approach of wind, dynamic going on in their relationships. With avoidantly attached people, avoidantly attached people, they're the kinds of people who you would think of as the independent type. They're the person who's likely to tell you that they don't really need relationships. You know, I always like to say that if you're the person when there's eight bags of groceries to carry from the car into the house that you want to take them all by yourself, you might be avoidantly attached. They're the kinds of people who don't really like to be reliant on other people, don't like to get a lot of help from other people. So we have a little bit of research looking at, you know, do these individual differences in how people relate to other people?
是否与他们在单身生活中的幸福感相关？结果证明，那些焦虑型依恋更严重的人——再次说明，这就是那些黏人和需要关注的类型——他们内心有种感觉，觉得如果没有其他人，自己很难独自度过一生。他们对单身并不怎么快乐。因此，单身且焦虑型依恋的人，其总体生活满意度相对较低。他们对单身生活的满意度也相对较低。所以他们会觉得自已非常需要一段恋爱关系。
Are they related to how happy people are in singlehood? And so it turns out the people who are more anxiously attached. And again, these are the needy and clingy type. They have a bit of a sense that they can't quite get through life without other people. They're not very happy with being single. So single, anxiously attached people are relatively low in their overall life satisfaction. they're relatively low in how satisfied they are with singlehood. So they feel like they really need a relationship.
我的意思是，对焦虑型依恋的人来说不幸的是，当他们真正进入恋爱关系时，他们的关系满意度往往也相对较低。所以这就像是他们内心有一个剧本：“只要我能谈恋爱，我就会好起来的。”但事实证明，这种想法并不太奏效。这绝对呼应了我之前所说的话：有些人可能需要首先自我完善，然后才能为恋爱做好准备。这可能特别适用于那些焦虑型依恋的人。
I mean, the unfortunate thing for anxiously attached people is that they also, when they do get into relationships, tend to have relatively low relationship satisfaction. So it's kind of like they have this story. If I just get into a relationship, I'll be okay. And it turns out that that doesn't quite work. And so that definitely goes back to what I was saying before, that there's some people who probably need to work on themselves first before. they're ready for a relationship. And that might particularly be the anxiously attached people.
回避型依恋的人则是一个有点奇特的案例，因为回避型依恋的人对单身并没有特别的不满。所以他们对单身的满意度并不比那些更具安全型依恋的人低，但他们整体的生活满意度似乎确实较低。所以他们引起了我的兴趣，因为他们说自己不讨厌单身，也没有特别表达出想要恋爱伴侣的愿望，但某种状况正在发生，导致他们在总体生活中感觉不那么快乐。我们对此进行过推测，这个想法来自于我的研究生兼优秀合作者尤本·帕克（Euben Park），她的想法我认为非常棒：对于回避型依恋的人来说，同样地，他们喜欢保持距离，对吧？他们不喜欢离别人
Avoidingly attached people are a bit of a curious case in that avoidantly attached people are not particularly unhappy about being single. So they're no less satisfied with singlehood than your more secure type of person, but they do seem to be lower in overall life satisfaction. So they're interesting to me because they say that they're not unhappy about being single. They don't report particularly wanting a romantic partner, but something is going on that's leading them to feel less happy in life overall. One of the things that we've speculated there, and this came from my graduate student an amazing collaborator, Euben Park, her idea, which I think is a really good one, is that with avoidantly attached people, again, they like distance, right? They don't like to get
太近，但这并不仅仅适用于他们的恋爱关系。正如我们之前所讨论的，要成为一个快乐的单身人士，拥有与家人和朋友的亲密关系会有很大帮助。而回避型依恋的人在这些领域也同样挣扎，因为他们在那里也保持着情感上的距离。确实有一些研究表明，对于这些回避型依恋的人来说，尽管在短期内避免这种关系让他们感觉更好或更轻松，但如果你真的在实验研究中稍微推他们一把，让他们进入某种情绪上亲密的情境中。我的意思是，我总是说，对回避型依恋的人来说，亲密感就像是运动。它在当下的感觉并不好，但从长远来看它能增强心理承受力，对吧？因此，他们确实能从这些亲密的互动中获得一些好处。只是他们似乎缺乏主动推动自己去经历这一切的动机。所以这就是我们认为回避型依恋的人之所以被单身所吸引的原因之一，因为你可以避开伴侣关系所带来的所有麻烦和冲突。但硬币的另一面是，你无法获得亲密关系带来的种种好处。你还探讨了一种被称为“进展偏差”的现象，据我理解，这就是人们倾向于留在恋爱关系中，哪怕这段关系其实并没有那么好。从演化的角度来看，我们是不是几乎可以说是被硬编码成：哪怕在并不理想的情况下，也极力想要维持伴侣关系？这是一个非常好的问题。是的。这是我和我的前博士生萨曼莎·乔尔（Samantha Joel）共同完成的一些研究，她现在是西安大略大学的教授。
too close to people, but that doesn't just apply to their romantic relationships. And as we talked about before, to be a happy single, it's going to help a lot to have close relationships with your family and with your friends. And avoidantly attached people struggle in those kinds of domains, too, because they keep their emotional distance there. And there is some research that suggests that this is avoidantly attached people, even though it feels better or easier for them in the short term, to avoid those kinds of relationships, if you actually do, like in an experimental study, kind of push them a little bit to get into an emotional, intimate situation. I mean, I always say that for avoidantly attached people, intimacy is like exercise. It doesn't feel good in the
所谓“进展偏差”的理念，其实就有点像我刚才谈到的那样。当你进入一段随意的性关系中，然后突然之间，你发现自己投入的承诺越来越深。我们认为这背后的原因可能有好几个。其中一个绝对是你刚才提到的演化视角。我们的想法是，我们的祖先在很久很久以前，对吧？如果你想想那些人数相对较少、以狩猎采集为生的群体，如果你采用那种在网上对每个人都向左滑、直到遇到
moment, but it builds capacity over the long term, right? And so they do seem to get something good out of those close interactions. They just don't seem to be motivated to push themselves into them. So that's one reason we think that avoidantly attached people are kind of attracted to being single because you can avoid all the problems and the conflicts that come with relationships. But the flip side of that is that you don't get the benefits of relationships. You've also looked at something called progression bias, which, as I understand it, is the tendency among people to stay in relationships even when they're not that great. From an evolutionary perspective, aren't we almost hardwired to try to stay coupled even when it's not optimal? It's a really good question. Yeah. So this is some work that I've done with my former PhD student, and she's now a professor at Western University, Samantha Joel.
绝对完美匹配的在线约会策略。我的意思是，你可能总共只能和30个人约会。你最终可能会拒绝所有人，并且因为没有和任何人交配，你也没法把自己的基因传递下去，对吧？如果人类的心灵在某种程度上被构建为能够轻易爱上某人并让这种关系相对轻松地运转下去，那么对于生活在那些相对较小群体中的人来说，这可能就是一种成功的策略。所以我们认为，处于恋爱关系中的人们确实带有一种偏向，倾向于
And the idea with progression bias is it's kind of like I was talking about before. when you get into a casual sexual relationship and then it's all of a sudden you find yourself more and more committed. What we think is that we think that there's a couple of reasons why this might be. And one of them is definitely the evolutionary case that you're bringing up there. That, you know, our thinking on this is our ancestors long, long ago, right? If you think about hunter-gatherer groups living in relatively small numbers of people, that if you kind of took the online dating strategy of like swiping left on everyone until you came to
维持关系的延续，有时哪怕这段关系并不是最幸福的，因为这在演化上可能是有用的。话虽如此，我们并不认为演化部分是故事的全部。正如我们今天所讨论的，各种社会和结构体系同样偏向于恋爱关系，给人们灌输一种“你本来就应该处于一段恋爱关系中”的观念。而我的实验室所争论的一点是，这有时会让人们很难察觉到其实自己单身时可能更快乐。
your absolute perfect match. I mean, there's only 30 people that you could possibly date. You might end up rejecting everybody, and you're not going to pass your jeans down because you're not mating with anybody, right? If the human heart is kind of built to just sort of fall for somebody and make that work relatively easily, then that might have been sort of a successful strategy for people living in those relatively small groups. And so we think that it is true that people in relationships are kind of biased toward
当你在一个期待亲密关系能带给你幸福的社会中长大时，你根本不会去寻找这种可能。因此我们认为，这里有两种非常强大的力量在发挥作用。一方面，我们确实认为人类的心灵有时会让自己“深陷”于伴侣关系中；但另一方面，我们也认为社会存在着巨大的压力，迫使人们去进入并维持恋爱关系。这就引发了一个问题：社会上针对单身生活的污名化，似乎正如你所说的那样无处不在。这真的是一件坏事吗？这对单身人士来说绝对是一件坏事。如果你试图建立一个社会，希望人们都死守在亲密关系里，那这棒极了。
keeping the relationship going, sometimes even if it's not the happiest relationship, because that might have been evolutionarily useful. But having said that, we don't think that the evolution part of it is the only part of the story. There's all kinds of social and structural systems, as we've talked about today, that are also biased towards relationships, that give people the sense that you're supposed to be in a relationship. And one of the things that we argue in my lab is make it hard for people to notice sometimes if they're happier being single.
但如果你是一个单身人士，想要保持单身，并且作为单身者过着自己最好、最快乐的生活，它就会成为人们生活中的一种非常消极的力量。我认为，针对单身人士的歧视所带来的问题之一在于，在某种程度上，它依然是一种被社会接受的污名。我认为人们已经在内心里默认了单身人士身上存在某些问题的观念。因此，当发生某些事情时，它甚至不感觉像是不公平的歧视，例如——数据已经显示过这一点——人们更有可能把公寓租给有伴侣的人，而不是单身的人，对吧？如果你遭遇了重大的健康危机，而你的社会支持系统是你最好的朋友，他们可能无法和你一起进入急诊室。但如果那是你的妻子或丈夫，那就完全没有问题。因此，这会在人们的生活中造成一些非常重大的阻碍。贝拉·德保罗（Bella DePaulo）是对此进行过广泛探讨的人，我认为她在这里提出了一个非常好的论点：这些力量不仅会对单身人士的生活造成负面影响，而且我认为许多人直到最近才意识到这些都是不公平的刻板印象。
You're not looking for that when you're raised in a society where you expect relationships to be what makes you happy. So we think that there's two really powerful forces happening. We do think that the human heart kind of, you know, gets itself stuck in relationships sometimes. But we also think there's a lot of social pressure to get into and to stay in relationships. Which raises the question of societal stigma then against singlehood, which seems you're saying is pervading. Is that really a bad thing? It's certainly a bad thing for single people. You know, if you're trying to, well, if you're trying to build a society where you want people to stay stuck in relationships, it's great.
你认为大流行病是否影响了某些人对单身生活的看法？我之所以这样问，是因为在大流行病初期，许多人都进行了严格的社交疏离。当时有大量的新闻报道称，社交疏离对单身人士而言尤其困难，特别是那些独居的人。这只是随着社交疏离结束而已经过去的一个临时插曲吗？还是你认为这会对人们对待和重视亲密关系的方式产生某种持久的影响？我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题。关于这一点并没有太多的数据。所以我现在只能进行一些推测。
But if you're a single person who wants to be single and is living their best and happiest life as a single person, it can be a really negative force in people's lives. And I think that one of the problems with discrimination against single people is that to a certain extent, it's still kind of an acceptable stigma. I think people have internalized the idea that there's something wrong with single people. And so it doesn't even feel like unfair discrimination when, for example, and this is something that data has shown, people are more likely to rent an apartment to somebody who's in a relationship than somebody who is single, right? That if you get into a big health crisis and your social support is your best friend, they may not be able to get into the emergency room with you. But if it's your wife or your husband, there's no problem there whatsoever. So it can create some really important barriers in people's lives. Bella DiPaulo is someone who's talked about this extensively, and I think she makes a really good argument here, that these are some forces that not only affect single people's lives negatively, but I think a lot of people are only just realizing that these are unfair stereotypes.
不过，我认为越来越多的人选择单身生活的原因在于，我们构建社会的方式让人们这样做变得越来越容易。经济体制的建立方式使得我们不再像100或200年前那样，需要高度依赖亲密他人。因此，那些真正渴望独立的人现在可以在现实层面上做到这一点。但我认为，大流行病在某种程度上是一个提醒。并不是因为顺应这种社会趋势有什么必然的绝对正确性，才导致越来越多的人选择单身。我认为人们只是在根据自己所生活的社会进行调整。在大流行期间，当人们更多地被困在家中时，你无法接触到那些让快乐单身生活变得轻松的社交网络。所以，举个例子，我认为围绕着大流行期间究竟是谁在
Do you think that the pandemic affected how some people think about being single? And I'm asking because at the beginning of the pandemic, many people were strictly social distancing. And there were lots of news stories about how social distancing was particularly difficult for single people, especially those who were living alone. Was that just a temporary blip that we're done with now that social distancing is over? Or do you think this is going to have some kind of lasting effect on how people treat and value relationships? I think that's a very interesting question. There's not a lot of data on this point. So I'm just going to go ahead and speculate now.
苦苦挣扎的讨论中，有很大一部分是关于有孩子的家庭，比如你如何在工作场所和孩子之间寻找平衡之类的话题。所有这些都完全合情合理。在大流行期间抚养孩子确实是一个巨大的挑战。但如果你查看数据，看看大流行期间谁最快乐、谁最不快乐，结果却是那些与伴侣和孩子同住的人最快乐，对吧？你可能会感到压力山大，但你受到了刺激。你不会感到无聊。过得最艰难的人反而是那些独自居住的人。正是环境中缺乏任何刺激和社交连接，才会真正带来极大的挑战。
But, you know, I think that the reason why more and more people have been living single is that we've been structuring society in a way that makes it easier and easier for people to do so. That, you know, the economic system is set up in a way that we don't need to be as dependent on close others as we did 100 or 200 years ago. So the people who really like their independence can do that in a practical kind of way now. But I think that the pandemic was kind of a reminder of that. It's not that more people are becoming single because there's something inevitably correct about the societal move. I think it's people are adjusting themselves to the society that they live in. And during the pandemic, when people were more housebound, you didn't have access to the kinds of social networks that make it easier to live as a happy single person. So, you know, for example, I think a lot of the discourse around, you know, who was really,
但是，你知道，我认为越来越多的人选择单身生活的原因是，我们的社会结构让人们这样做变得越来越容易。你知道，经济体制的建立方式使得我们不像100或200年前那样需要过分依赖亲密的人。所以那些非常喜欢独立的人现在可以用一种很实际的方式做到这一点。但我认为大流行在某种程度上提醒了这一点。并不是说因为这种社会转变有什么不可避免的正确性，所以有更多的人成为单身。我认为人们只是在适应他们所生活的社会。在大流行期间，当人们更多地呆在家里面时，你无法获得那些能让你作为快乐的单身人士生活得更容易的社交网络。所以，你知道，例如，我认为关于谁真正...
struggling during the pandemic. A lot of this discourse is, you know, people with kids, for example, you know, how do you balance the workplace and kids and all this kind of stuff? All of which is totally valid. You know, having kids during the pandemic was a real challenge. But when you look at the data as to who was the most happy versus who was the least happy during the pandemic, it was people living with partners and children who were the most happy, right? You might be stressed, but you're stimulated. You're not bored. The people were having the hardest time were the people who were living by themselves. that there is something about just not having any stimulation and social connection in your environment that can be really challenging.
在大流行期间苦苦挣扎。很多这样的讨论都是关于，你知道的，比如有孩子的家庭，你知道，如何在职场和孩子之间取得平衡以及所有这些事情？所有这些都是完全合理的。你知道，在大流行期间生孩子是一个真正的挑战。但是，当你查看关于大流行期间谁最幸福与谁最不幸福的数据时，你会发现与伴侣和孩子一起生活的人是最幸福的，对吧？你可能会感到压力，但你得到了刺激。你不会感到无聊。过得最艰难的人是那些独居的人。你的环境中缺乏任何刺激和社交联系，这确实会带来很大的挑战。
So I think that was something that got people to think twice anyways about, you know, how sustainable is a single life. And then I think it's interesting to think about what are the future social structural changes that might drive people into different kinds of living circumstances. So, for example, you know, here in Toronto, rent and house prices are out of control. that people who might have been able to afford to live on their own in the past are going to be forced into more group living situations. But maybe when you've got a roommate, that accounts for some of the need that you might have had a romantic partner for. So maybe there's another force that leads people to be less motivated to be in romantic relationships. So I think it's completely unpredictable. Are people going to be living single more or be living single less?
所以我觉得无论如何，这让人们开始三思，你知道的，单身生活究竟能维持多久。接着，我认为去思考未来可能会推动人们进入不同居住环境的社会结构变化是一件很有趣的事情。比如，你知道的，在多伦多这里，租金和房价已经失控了。过去可能买得起自己房子的人，现在将被迫进入更多的群居环境中。但也许当你有了室友，这就满足了你原本可能需要浪漫伴侣才能满足的一些需求。所以也许有另一种力量导致人们对处于恋爱关系的积极性降低。因此我认为这完全是不可预测的。人们是会更多地单身，还是更少地单身？
I think it really depends on, you know, what happens to society and what are the opportunities and challenges for single people. So I think that's the important thing to remember is that it's not just some, you know, amazing moral choice to live single or to not live single. All of us are trying to just get by in the society that we live in. And that society is constantly changing. This is a relatively young field with a lot of wide open questions. And I'm wondering what are some of the most important research questions that you still want to explore? I'd say that the thing that is in the front of our mind in my lab right now is that, and you know, maybe this is a little bit because we came to singlehood research as relationship
我认为这确实取决于，你知道的，社会会发生什么，以及单身人士面临的机会和挑战是什么。所以我觉得需要记住的重要一点是，单身或不单身并不仅仅是某种令人惊叹的道德选择。我们所有人都在努力在我们生活的社会中勉强维生。而这个社会在不断变化。这是一个相对年轻的领域，有许多悬而未决的问题。我想知道，你仍然想探索的最重要的研究问题有哪些？我想说，目前在我们实验室里，我们最关心的事是，而且你知道的，也许这在一定程度上是因为我们作为恋爱关系研究人员进入了单身研究领域。
researchers. And so I think that as we've been doing singlehood research, a lot of our focus has been on, are they dating? Do they want to date? Are they having sex? Do they want to have sex? And so our focus has been this narrow kind of dating and sexual domain. But we've started to do some studies that I've alluded to a little bit where we're asking
研究人员。因此我认为，在我们进行单身研究的过程中，我们的许多重点一直放在：他们在约会吗？他们想约会吗？他们在过性生活吗？他们想过性生活吗？所以我们的焦点一直局限在约会和性这一个狭窄的领域。但我们已经开始做一些我稍早提到过的研究，我们在其中询问
about single people's broader lives and refining out things like sex and dating is relatively low on their priority list, that things like their health, things like their workplace, for example, are really important factors. So I think because, in a sense, single people are defined as people who have the absence of a romantic relationship that's led us to think that everything about their life surrounds a romantic relationship. I think for a lot of happy singles, they don't even think about romantic relationships. There's a lot of other parts of their life that are more important, but I don't think we've done a good enough job of studying single people's lives holistically in that sense. Well, it sounds like a really interesting area to be researching. Thank you for joining me
关于单身人士更广泛的生活，并弄清楚诸如性与约会之类的事情在他们的优先级列表中相对较低，而诸如他们的健康、他们的工作场所等事情，确实是非常重要的因素。所以我认为，从某种意义上说，单身人士被定义为缺乏浪漫关系的人，这导致我们认为他们生活的一切都围绕着浪漫关系。我认为对于许多快乐的单身人士来说，他们根本不考虑浪漫关系。他们生活中有许多其他部分更重要，但我认为我们还没有很好地从整体上去研究单身人士的生活。嗯，听起来这是一个非常有趣的研究领域。感谢你今天加入我的节目，
today, Dr. McDonald. I really appreciated your taking the time. It's been my pleasure. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
麦克唐纳博士。非常感谢你拨冗前来。这是我的荣幸。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 www. speakingof psychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《Speaking of Psychology》之前的单集。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。本播客由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音响编辑是克里斯·孔丁（Chris Kondyin）。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。